this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you know
cash app it's the simplest way to
instantly send money to friends it's
also the number one app in finance but
it didn't get there on payments alone
these days cash app is changing how
people interact with their money it's
adding features so you can only get from
its adding features you can only get
from a bank and more than a few that you
can't like the cash card boosts and
Bitcoin download the cash app for free
on the App Store or Google Play market
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know a lot of people were like
where's the [ __ ] podcast yesterday
even though I say time and time again
it's gonna be out Monday or Tuesday
Wichita Kansas I'm common Kansas City
Missouri Lincoln and Nevada this is the
follow-the-leader tour look you want to
come to the follow-the-leader tour you
go crystally a.com you buy tickets
you're sitting there at your desk right
now you want to come see me at Carnegie
Hall you want to come see me in
Montclair New Jersey you gonna come see
me in washington d.c chris d'elia calm
for tickets this is episode 79 and we're
broadcasting live on my app so they're
getting the podcast a little bit earlier
than anyone else is and those are the
real babies baby those are the real
babies my babies a so I I was in
Montreal dude I've been traveling
non-stop I've been not on the road I've
been not at home I've been on the road
and it's been a lot and I'm now back for
two and a half weeks and I'm very happy
because it was getting to me it was
getting to me my babies and you know
what it's okay but that's what was
happening you know every now and then
you got to put in a little bit overtime
you got to put in a little bit of work
and the [ __ ] crumples up and piles up
and you gets just got to grin and bear
it and get right through it now
hopefully you're making bags
hopefully when you do with that your
step you're stacking chips you're making
bags but sometimes you're not sometimes
you're building a [ __ ] you're you're
setting the building blocks for your
career and you're doing it for free I
did that I did that when I was coming up
I did a lot of shows for free now my
sweating bullets already now yeah are we
all are we two minutes in yeah is it all
right I mean the bottom line is yeah
nobody's gonna die am I gonna look like
a mess in the video pockets yeah it's
gonna I'm gonna look like Brendan Fraser
in school ties when he's like screaming
at the guys in the in the in the school
and he's like ah yeah cowards or
whatever the [ __ ] am I gonna look like
that yeah um but I was in Montreal I
just got back from the gym which you
ever go to the gym or workout or
whatever and then you take a shower you
put on your clothes and then you leave
and you're still sweating balls and it
looks like and you're like I should have
waited longer to take the shower but you
want your you're a businessman you're
[ __ ] you gotta wait I mean you can't
wait you got to hurry up you got [ __ ] to
do I had this podcast to do I had babies
waiting I had to [ __ ] shower and put
on a shirt now up and I'm sweating my
balls off um but I by the way man a lot
of you guys have been listening this
podcast has been growing last episode
was the number one watched and listened
to episode there is so man we are
getting these babies going and we are
[ __ ] some of you babies are one years
old you know you've been watching
listening to the podcast for a year now
but I was just at the gym dude I swear
to God I saw a [ __ ] guy there working
out with I I actually I couldn't believe
my eyes I want to tell you guys I see a
lot of crazy [ __ ] and a lot of people
like why do you see the most crazy [ __ ]
and you work because I talk about it a
lot and I [ __ ] to eat wheat tweet
about it and I put pictures up about it
I talk a lot about crazy [ __ ] that I see
people always like why do you see the
crazy [ __ ] I don't know dude I don't
know if it's that I'd like to think that
I'm [ __ ] super observant but I don't
know what it is maybe just crazy find
certain people maybe I am that way and
it radiates and it makes crazy people
gravitate towards me I don't
but I see a lot of crazy [ __ ] and I'm
not lying to you
this could have taken the cake they do
have a towel in there by the way his
Reni tells ya dude thanks dude
I [ __ ] you not I saw a guy working out
today and one fire already knows because
of the group text but I I saw Ivan get
rid of dozen I saw a guy working out
with [ __ ] first of all had a gold
watch on ah don't have a gold wrought
watch on ah because it's working out
it's gonna get in the way now I have a
[ __ ] silver watch on ah if I worked
out in it but I don't he also had a
[ __ ] clear baggie with a stack I
would almost say a brick of hundreds
with a rubber band wrapped around the
hundreds and he would take it from place
to place while he worked out and while
he did a set he'd put it down
ah dude he worked out with a brick with
a stack of hundreds I saw it I laughed
hard that's what that guy deserves do it
I'll tell you what every now and then
there's [ __ ] that happens where people
do some [ __ ] like that and then if you
laugh for real in their face I hope they
really get embarrassed like here's
something that happened that happened
here's something that happened at the
comedy festival I mean first of all who
the [ __ ] brings a stack of hundreds to
the gym I mean there are guys that work
out in sunglasses there are guys that
work out with gold chains on this guy go
chain obviously by the way and a black
tank top exposing his nipples but like
dude you work out in a shirt and shorts
and that's it you don't need to bring a
stack hundreds the guy brought a stack
of hundreds he's trying to get a [ __ ]
mate is he trying to get chicks at the
gym it's also the worst place to try and
get chicks it's the worst place to try
and hit on a girl it's just like if
you're a guy and you hit on a girl at
the gym you're a [ __ ] idiot
it's just they are in their own world
let them work out you don't need to hit
on them dude okay but also if you're a
chick she doing she doin if you're
showing [ __ ] cleavage at the gym I get
it when you go out and you know girls
can wear whatever they
I'm not saying ah you know I know you're
yeah I get it feminists wear whatever
you want guys still have to treat you
like a real purse but come on dude
what are you showing you [ __ ]
cleavage out for the gym you got a cute
suit on you want to work out in a cute
suit and [ __ ] dogs will be dogs man
well I want to go to workout with only
those nipple tassels that they had in
the [ __ ] 40s all right man now when
they used to dance at that [ __ ] and work
out in that and then when a guys like
sup
I want a girl it would be like what the
[ __ ] let me work out in peace and then
go all right man now and just doing
those like doing like deadlifts with way
too light of weight um one fire I was
looking up a video called how to twirl
your tassels sir perv so so but yeah
there's a so there's a it looks stupid
when girls do that I mean why is she
[ __ ] saluting you know hey not in the
Navy you're naked anyway so I was at jfl
just for laughs in Montreal and this was
this is the thing I was talking about
kind of like when you laugh in
somebody's face so there's this guy at
jail you know comedians are [ __ ] nuts
they do their [ __ ] they as the Luke
Bryan would say they're just doing their
thing we're a song of all time doing my
thang yeah everyone's doing their thing
okay so anyway this there you know
comedians they do [ __ ] sometimes they
have wacky hair which is [ __ ] awful
you know it's like just have a regular
haircut but this guy had like I don't
even it wasn't a mohawk but it was
gelled up to like a point like a pointy
kind of a thing almost kind of a mohawk
but it looked like a [ __ ] [ __ ] it was
like a big black hair [ __ ] and it's
always this is the best - the guy was
like five nine it's like if you're gonna
do that beat tallish [ __ ] so people are
like alright he's a real man but if
you're like five nine and have wacky
hair you're [ __ ] you're five nine
dude you know what I mean your hair is
most of your body then if you're six
three and you want to [ __ ] kill it
with a mohawk you'd be like all right
look that guy is a big beefy guy and
he's
lanky and he looks like he would have
and give him a chain he looks like a bad
guy from Double Dragon the videogame but
this guy was 5-9 and had a wacky hair
which means about 15 to 20 percent of
his height was his hair so he was about
my height with his hair sad sad bad
childhood so and was gelled up into a
[ __ ] like [ __ ] thing and and he
walked by and this is just for Laughs
comedy festival and I was with my agents
and this guy walked by and my agent was
like loo this [ __ ] guy first of all
nobody respects you if you have wacky
hair do you know what I'm talking about
have a reg unless you're unless you you
know the only people that respect you
are people that are like hipsters and
[ __ ] lost like nobody who's an actual
money-making businessman is like alright
cool man anyway this guy had this and he
was walking around and we're at the
comedy festival major was like look at
this [ __ ] guy and I said and I said
oh look it's [ __ ] comic - Hedgehog
now that that weekend there wasn't a
better joke okay comic the Hedgehog
that's [ __ ] hilarious all right now
all my jokes aren't great
I actually don't do a lot of jokes I
mostly just razz in Dad's and have a
good time and Joker and and be silly you
know I'm down for a silly goose time and
that's it I'm not doing these [ __ ]
punchline shits
but comic the Hedgehog shut it down to
it we're done we're done
my agent laughed so hard he started
crying right now look at this man I'm
not I'm not I'm not being braggadocious
it was just a good one when you got a
good slam you got a good slam that was a
slam behind closed doors I wasn't
looking in his eyes and [ __ ] giving
him the the 8 then the nine eighty nine
[ __ ] super slam at Denny's not not to
his table put I was back in the kitchen
like oh I think that guy wants a [ __ ]
super slam right it's his birthday maybe
we'll give it to him for free but this
guy I said comic the Hedgehog now here's
the deal man
if I walked up to that guy and said hey
look it's comic the Hedgehog right that
such a super [ __ ] real-deal slam
everyone he'd have to go home he'd have
to go home because it's so [ __ ] he
thought he was ill having that [ __ ]
[ __ ] sonic the hedghog care and I said
hey look it's kamek to head right and
then everyone else around him left he
literally has to go like this oh dude I
got a pack and get on a plane and leave
if you're gonna have hair like that be
[ __ ] indestructible now I don't know
that guy I don't even know who it was I
just on the back of him but you got to
be have the ultimate confidence you
can't be so [ __ ] at all if you have
hair like that you got to be like yup
[ __ ] you goddamn right I got
this hair sit on it dude sit on it it's
a dildo sit on it this guy was walking
around five nine all [ __ ] like though I
didn't see his face I don't know I have
no idea also be fit if you have hair
like that you know what I'm talking
about have the rest of you pristine have
the rest of you just top-notch cyborg
type [ __ ] right if you're just like
pudgy and you have hair like that what
are you doing instead of [ __ ] styling
your hair do burpees take the 30 minutes
it takes for you to [ __ ] style your
hair up into a [ __ ] [ __ ] and do
burpees why this called burpees I hate
that name burpees it's like name it some
ELLs jumping jacks is kind of [ __ ]
shitty too but that was made so long ago
you know that's so so an old timey
[ __ ] name for a workout jumping jacks
do the jumping jacks huh you're gonna do
jumping jacks that'll keep you fit
anyway so I did just for laughs I did my
Netflix special you know I'm gonna stop
calling specials everybody's got one
that'll be like this guy from oh my god
burpees are from this guy
whose name was royal H Burpee hey also
how do you have a worse first name then
[ __ ] if your last name is Burpee
Royal sit on it sit down buddy
physiologist you know the guy [ __ ]
figured out how to jump up and down and
do a push-up there already by the way
there are already things jumping and
push-up guy ain't [ __ ] you just put two
things together you know imagine
figuring that out being the guy where
you're just like you go down you go into
a plank you jump up you go down you've
core there's nothing dude
also this guy's name is taco floor
what's wrong with everybody
taco floor is demonstrating the Burpee
man everything's so [ __ ] crazy so
look I did my Netflix I've got a sub
home specials everybody has I found it I
there was employ at IKEA that's like
edge is coming first next flicks with
Netflix petrol but they're hours so my
so I did it and it's a it was a heist a
half-hour it's the news this new global
thing that Netflix is doing which
they're all releasing at the same time
and I'm excited about and they asked me
to do it and I did it because I've got a
half-hour of material that I don't mind
burning and I want to not have it on my
next hour so I I did it and the first
taping we shoot it you shoot these
things twice for those you guys that
don't know well if you're lucky issued
these things twice sometimes if you are
shooting yourself you only do it once
because it's more expensive the more
time you use and the more equipment you
use and the more shows you do so shot it
twice and we did one the first show what
they did is we shot three of them
together so it was me me it they shot
this episode twice it was me they're
doing like 47 of these from all around
the world they got like comedians
representing Brazil comedians
representing French Canada regular
Canada Asia and you know South Africa
America and I was one of the comedians
that is representing America with Neal
Brennan
and Nicole Byer and also Nick Swardson
now they coupled him up differently so
they put me Nick Swardson and then K
Trevor Noah
Trevor Kitchener Wilson I always do that
Trevor Noah is a comedian and and
obviously the guy that does the Comedy
Central Daily Show uh the one higher
racking up some points when I reckon up
some points gave me some [ __ ] told me
it was a good show and but also a one
fire for interrupting but still helped
so it's all good so it's back to zero
let's just say so wha so it's okay it's
okay Trevor Wilson so it was us three on
that show and then Neal Brennan
Neal Brennan and Nicole Byer performed
it different than the night doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it doesn't
[ __ ] matter at all still just giving
you the lowdown right so we went now the
first show was me then k Trevor Wilson
then Nick Swardson
the second time we taped it an hour
later it was Nick Swardson me then k
Trevor Wilson so the first show started
at seven o'clock now I don't know you
probably don't know much about x and one
shows starting comedy the general rule
is the later shows are better unless
they start at like 11:00 right because
then people are drunk as [ __ ] but the
general rule is that this is the general
I was gonna say and then I got
sidetracked instead the thing about that
later shows if you're doing stand-up and
it's still light outside it's going to
be way tougher now seven o'clock in the
summer on Montreal its way north it's
[ __ ] bright until like 8:30
alright so seven o'clock these guys
piled in and I knew who's gonna be kind
of tight I had to go first so I had to
kind of do that when they had a warm-up
but it wasn't it but it was like still
[ __ ] early I had to go and the crowd
was so tight I couldn't [ __ ] believe
it it was so tight I couldn't believe it
sang a crowd is tight means there
[Music]
they're not giving it up right not
laughing a lot and it was tough dude and
I was like this sucks that this is my
Netflix taping so this and then I was
like well maybe I'll at least warm it up
for the other guys being a good person
being really nice it's what Jesus would
have done so then que Trevor Wilson went
up and it was [ __ ] tight man and then
Nick Swardson went up and it was tight
so we then we're like I don't know again
we did it again
and it was great I [ __ ] it was an
awesome show really happy and props to
the other guys that did it with me Nick
Swardson it's [ __ ] hilarious que
Trevor Wilson [ __ ] hilarious and I'm
excited to see them dude
I'm excited to have them come out and
we'll see I don't know I get to look at
the Edit today actually they're gonna
send it over so that should be out I
think early next year anyway be on the
lookout for that that's it I don't know
where 18 minutes in 19 minutes in got
nothin else to talk about
yeah oh no I do actually when I was in
Montreal by the way here's two things
happen in Montreal right after my
Netflix taping okay walked out some guy
you know we walk out especially the
comedy festival there's lots of comedy
fans so they'll recognize you more so I
was walking down the street this is one
long one one Street that everything's on
st. Catherine I think it's called anyway
I walk down the street and some guy says
Chris D'Elia
you mispronounced my name I don't
remember how but I was like yeah almost
what's up and he said I just wanted to
shake your hand shakes my hand this guy
was a one of those guys that like you
could tell he worked out a lot but he
was also one of those fat workout guys
you know what I'm talking about where
it's like oh [ __ ] stop eating carbs if
you want a good body maybe you don't
maybe you just want to be beefy you want
to be those one of those guys that
[ __ ] you know carries tires around
outside instead of that you know you
want to be one of those guys with like a
hairy back
you know I'm talking about like those
big beefy strong guys with hairy backs
that carry around tires and they wear
one-piece [ __ ] workout suits that's
what this guy looked like except he had
on a yellow shirt and the shirt said
[ __ ] blocker literally that was his
shirt so I knew immediately this guy is
an [ __ ] all right so I shook his hand
he said I just wanted to personally men
won't fire you're gonna love this but he
said I just want to personally shake
your hand and tell you to go [ __ ]
yourself that's what he said to me okay
it's not the part you're gonna love this
is the part you're gonna love and I said
really
like I was like this will be interesting
I thought maybe he was joking but I was
like what's the deal and he said dude
four years ago on Facebook and so now
I'm like wow I cannot wait for this [ __ ]
I did something I [ __ ] gave him a
super slam whatever I did maybe I wrote
back to him maybe I put it on Instagram
can't wait
he says four years ago on faith this guy
was telling me this with more oomph then
like the I had a dream speech this guy
breathed in puffed his [ __ ] fat
carved out chest outward with his [ __ ]
blocker shirt on and blue shorts yellow
shirt with blue shorts this guy was
dressing like he was eight okay and he
had I had on with like headphones this
guy was a [ __ ] bubblegum loser okay
now he says to me four years ago on
Facebook I made fun of you and I said
okay and he said yup and I said that's
it
and he said uh-huh suck my [ __ ] and then
he said the f-word which I won't say you
know this slanted derogatory term for
gays right and I said all right man I
literally love like making fun of the
guys and like coming back at him but I
was like what am what else and he was
like yup and then he goes like this
[ __ ] you man and I was like okay and I
walked away that's it
this guy had a [ __ ] [ __ ] blocker
shirt on it was yellow blue shorts said
all that to me I had like a [ __ ]
orange his beard and and that's it that
was the whole story and then I went back
to the Hyatt where I was staying at the
hotel now I was with my agent and my and
my agent was like I can't believe you
deal with that [ __ ] I was like well I've
never dealt with that you know but he
was like man I would snap all the time I
was like yeah I was with my agent and
then I was with my Australian promoter
right that he'd to promote my Australian
tour and so we get back to the Hyatt
Hotel we're on the patio we're away from
me we're away from the business you know
the hotels just loaded with [ __ ]
industry and and comedians and [ __ ] and
we get a drink you know I'm drinking a
club soda and they're drinking some
they're having a smoke or whatever I'm
we're outside the patio and this guy
comes up to me and he's just he's one of
these just obviously flamboyant he's
obviously gay guy walks up and he's one
of these gay guys that just looks like
he's like always trying to find out how
to stand you know what I'm talking about
he's just like so swishy and he it looks
like he's a melting into his full form
but he didn't do it yet and you're just
like we'll figure it out dude
you know how are you gonna stand you
know guys that are so flamboyant that
are just like hey and they're just
floating around where it's just like hey
man figure out the stance then we'll
have a conversation but this guy never
stops swishing around okay he was like
an angel and he says I remember you from
last yeah and that's how he said it like
he was about to take over the world like
he was an evil scientist with a boner
that's how he sounded okay and he says I
remember you from a last yeah
and the word year was longer than the
rest of the whole sentence and I said oh
yeah and he said um I sucked your [ __ ]
and I said uh uh yeah
and he said mm-hmm I said I don't know
man I don't think you sucked my [ __ ] all
right now this is fresh off the [ __ ]
story from the guy yelling me at me
outside calling me a [ __ ] you know
the f-word right so I'm like okay um
well you know I don't what to say by the
way he was with another chick
all right and you know how like when a
guy who's super drunk or something like
because I was obviously a little bit
drunk this comes up and acts a full
quote-unquote to somebody else right now
I mean I'm I can be a nice guy this
guy's just [ __ ] talking whatever I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm it's funny to me
so I'm like I'm like where's this goin
you know you know when you're with
somebody for somebody came up to three
guys and did this it's like be careful
dude like what if I was like [ __ ] you
I'm not gay you know this and that
whatever I don't give a [ __ ] but so you
know when you're with somebody and that
happens if something happens like that
and they're with somebody the other
person is like all right dude come on
let's go you're drunk let's leave right
the chick was standing there like yep if
he says he sucked your [ __ ]
he suck your [ __ ] and I was like all
right
and he he was like yep and you got so
mad at me because I wouldn't swallow and
I was like this happened last year and
he said yep and I was like I think you
might have the wrong guy and then she
was like the girl was like yep it
happened last year I was like I looked
at my agent in my [ __ ] Australian
promoter and I was like hey I was like
what the [ __ ] is happening tonight
and then my Australian and then and then
the guy touches my Australian promoter
and like rubs his [ __ ]
arm and he's like you're a big boy and I
was like geez just like I know my
promote my buddy his name is Andrew but
I was like don't do this to a random guy
don't touch a guy like that you know and
and then he's just like all right buddy
go away you know you had enough cuz he
was there for like a three minutes
trying to explain how I [ __ ] sucked my
dick and he was like alright whatever
guys [ __ ] off like like we were the bad
guy like what like nothing happened I
felt like this was guy was gonna be like
three years ago on Facebook I saw this
guy made fun of yeah it was so [ __ ]
weird man it was just a weird night and
all those nights where was like what the
[ __ ] kept happy those lights are awesome
though I'll forget that in a week I'm
glad I have it immortalized on my
podcast Montreal was lit man comic the
Hedgehog comic the Hedgehog dude I want
to see that guy you know what [ __ ]
guys like that who have like wacky hair
or like the points in their hair or like
super gelled hair like they go to sleep
and then they wake up and they don't
look like that you know that's the best
their hair looks real bad at that point
cuz it's like super long or whatever
what if a robber came in and tried to
steal their [ __ ] and killed them that
way then the police found him and he
didn't have his comic the Hedgehog hair
on and he was just saying they were like
yeah I don't know what happened and
they're like well let's look into his
hair maybe that had something to do with
it because that's how weird it was
[Music]
alright let's do these ads babies quit
no matter who you are you've got teeth
in your mouth brushing your teeth is one
of the most important parts of your day
to stay healthy
quit knows that and their team of
dentists and designers is focused on
helping you take care of your mouth
better quip was called the best electric
toothbrush by GQ and the Tesla of
toothbrushes by Bloomberg hmm is that a
good review um you think I'm gonna be
one of those guys from now on um you
think um hello you think for starters
quip is an electric toothbrush that has
a that's a fraction of the cost of
bulkier brushes I take it on the road
with me it's awesome it looks like Apple
designed it and it packs a punch man it
has guiding pulses that tell you that
they vibrate and then it's time to
switch size and it's not noisy it's a
it's like really cool you feel like
you're driving a Prius
you know quips subscription plans are
for your health not just convenience
they deliver new brush heads on a
dentist dentist recommended schedule
every three months for just five dollars
including free shipping worldwide equip
also comes with a mount that suctions
right to your mirror it unsticks for
easy travel use quip starts at just $25
and if you go to get quip comm /
Congrats right now you'll get your first
refill pack free with equip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
free at get quip calm / Congrats that's
spelled GE tqu yp.com / Congrats I'm
gonna talk to you guys about a new thing
that I've been using that's a really
great company and my dogs love it dog
food company it's called farmers dog now
dog food companies claim to use all
natural ingredients but what kind of
beef or carrots can sit on a shelf for
years hmm do you know that we can't eat
highly prod set processed food every
meal and be healthy and neither can your
dog your dog is basically a person the
healthiest food for your dog is real
fresh unprocessed food okay
farmers dog I'm introducing this to me
you guys on my podcast the farmer's dog
the company helping dogs live longer and
healthier lives with fresh ready to
serve meals delivered directly to your
door clever marketing has convinced pet
owners to feed unhealthy and highly
processed kibble but the farmers dog is
different it arrives at your door
pre-portioned in packs ready to open and
pour it's easy and it looks and smells
like real food because it is real food
doesn't smell bad food matters studies
show that even adding fresh food to your
dog's diet can reduce cancer risk by 90%
okay
by the way my dogs love this food
sometimes they eat food like here and
there it's like they pick at it they
scarf this food down
they really do it's a super cute
actually start start feeding your dog
better today get 50% off your two week
trial of fresh healthy food at the
farmer's dog com / Congrats plus you get
free shipping just go to the farmer's
dog com / congrats to get your 50% off
your first two weeks that's
farmers dog.com slash Congrats hey man
you love dogs
you love your dog treat it like you you
love it right square cache the cache app
you know the cache app it's the simplest
way to instantly send money to friends
it's also the number one app in finance
the cache card is a free customizable
debt car debit card that you can use at
stores or ATMs it's linked to your cash
balance it's linked to your cash app
balance as if it were a checking account
it even lets you direct deposit to your
paycheck if you're looking for an
alternative to traditional banking
you're not alone millions of Americans
have already started using the cash card
there's never been a rewards program
like boosts they're ahead of the wave
it's awesome get instant discounts every
single time you swipe your cash card at
coffee shops Chipotle Shake Shack and
Beyond and of course when you download
the cash app and enter rewards code
Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now and look 20 years ago
something like cash app would have been
really hard to imagine and now it's kind
of hard to imagine anything else to it
so use it like I do we taken over one
city at a time we taking over one city
at a time that was free for you guys
that's free for you guys I'm just kind
of [ __ ] we taken over one city at a
time you're welcome free for you guys
dude I'm in a good mood man I worked out
got it out the way sweating balls off
it's all good having a good one
got the new Follow the Leader shirts
going those are flying off the shelves
like hotcakes so you know they're very
cool they're a nice color crystal it
Chris Leo calm what am I looking forward
to in the next few weeks
chillin burned 30 minutes of material so
now I'm I'm gonna be doing writing some
new stuff I got a
do the new hour at the end of next year
probably for Netflix so I got a I got a
work on that doing some new material and
then that's it I'm on the show called
alone again alone together dude this
show so funny man I'm really lucky to be
on it I mean you know at first I was
like I'll yeah they're my buds Esther
and Ben gene it was a show that wasn't
even picked up yet but it got picked up
and dude it's so funny you guys gotta
watch this on freeform I don't know how
you get your free form for me I watch it
on app on Apple TV but yeah that's it
I have something wanted to talk about
and I don't run what it was did I love
you guys man you just [ __ ] you just
[ __ ] or with me do you know what I'm
talking about I get my ants these I get
my aunt these start a Starbuck you know
the Starbucks cups that they have the
you are here collection or whatever and
you can go and every time you go to
Starbucks you get the [ __ ] cups it's
such a sucker move but it's such good
marketing I love the cups and I buy them
from my aunt every time I go I get her
wherever I go like I was in Houston I
got her a cue someone already got her to
the Houston one but I was there last
like two weekends ago and I already got
I already got her that one so didn't go
to that one but I got her one in like
didn't have one in Maine couldn't get
one in Maine trying to get one they are
gonna Reno I wonder if they've won in
Reno's I know she doesn't have a ring
you know um we gotta get her these cups
man she's got like 40 of them she loves
putting them out dude how about ladies
man ladies are cute
you know what I'm talking about they
have all their [ __ ] long as so many
[ __ ] tchotchkes it's ridiculous there
wasn't a wall there wasn't a spot on her
wall not covered it's like the real
trophies man she loves tchotchkes man
swear to god she didn't give a [ __ ] what
they are if I bought her like a ceramic
eagle she'd be like oh my god that's
that's the sweet I find a place of her
it in the bathroom
she loves it man
girls love collecting [ __ ] you know guys
love going to get the [ __ ]
hunter-gatherers [ __ ] right that's what
that is how crazy is it that now it
turned into that
oh mama has so many tchotchkes I
I [ __ ] hate tchotchkes man when I was
a kid I like like I I collected [ __ ]
like you know first of all I collected
baseball cards and I also collected
comic books but beyond that like any
time there was something cool like I
remember one of the things I had were
FRA I like and when McDonald's or some
like fast food company would do like
these like promotional things for movies
I remember there was one for Batman
Forever and they had like Happy Meals or
even though there weren't even Happy
Meals but they were like because I don't
think I'd get Happy Meals but they were
like the fry covers would be like the
penguin or like the Riddler or like
Batman Robin and I would get them and
I'd always want them different one
that I didn't have and I'd get them and
I saved them like my fry holders and I
would save [ __ ] like that like I got
into pogs remember pogs we'd [ __ ]
slam him
I collected um I had sheets of pogs I
collected so many [ __ ] dumb things
man
like I was a real sentiment I'm still
sentimental but I was a sentimental kid
so I'd keep all the kid [ __ ] and then
one day I looked at my desk and I was
like oh no dude I'm gonna be a hoarder I
literally thought that I don't even know
if I knew what a hoarder was but I was
I'm gonna be one of those pack rat
[ __ ] that just has a bunch of
[ __ ] and and I'm gonna [ __ ] keep keep
too much [ __ ] and what by the time I
move out of my parents house I'm gonna
be like a mess I'm never gonna get
chicks they're gonna be like it this is
a nice place where do I step right and
so I with one fell swoop I was like if I
don't throw away all this [ __ ] right now
I'll never do it so I threw all and I lo
and one of the things was I looked the
fry holders and it were all old and
greasy with the [ __ ] fry it was gross
so I was like there's gonna I'm gonna
throw him away throw all the way I never
collected a thing after that it was like
a [ __ ] purge dude it was awesome
and now I'm a better person because of
that you got to realize we got early on
or otherwise you [ __ ] if you
too late you're [ __ ] you're already
set in your ways baby you have to be a
self-reflective 12 year old guess what
it's too late for you you're done [ __ ]
up
and so am i we're all [ __ ] in our own
way we're all a certain kind of [ __ ]
up figuring it out we're trying but you
know and we think we all have it figured
out too even if we say we don't we still
[ __ ] secretly think we have it
figured out for a moment a moment that's
so [ __ ] maybe it's all I thought at
the whole or like I don't know but
moments a moment we're like [ __ ] sure
[ __ ] I try to keep my OCD at bay you
know it's tough you know I told you that
JoJo's cup story it manifests itself in
weird ways and it wasn't even that I
wanted JoJo's this was a those you that
don't know this it's on an earlier
episode called JoJo's Cup but it wasn't
even in it wasn't even a a German thing
mine has nothing to do with germs
it was a that's her cup that's
designated for her I don't use it
it's a weird [ __ ] thing I don't take
drinks from other people's drinks I'll
eat a sandwich I'll take a bite from
their [ __ ] but for some reason I got a
locked in my head I don't do that and it
has nothing to do with germs I mean it
does if you look like a [ __ ] if you
got like you know gross [ __ ] mouth
going on then am i and you keep it you
know but uh yeah it's [ __ ] weird how
a mental [ __ ] can affect you right
I think about that a lot lately actually
like leaders how they can like make like
it cuz I was watching the Sacha Baron
Cohen thing which is amazing
who is America and I'm like how the [ __ ]
do they get these people to do this man
how funny was the Roy Moore one were
they [ __ ] you saw it where they were
like the guy like [ __ ] wandered him
and there was a pedophile one and it
went off and then Roy Moore was like
I've never ever been like called been
accused of such a thing and it's like
haha yes you have by nine people it's
Google it you're you you definitely know
about it that's how you know he's lying
cuz you lied about that I've never been
accused
really google it nine nine kids at
Mooney wrote away and his horse that
little bitch-ass God if you're gonna
ride a horse you better [ __ ] ride
that [ __ ] don't be a [ __ ] ass don't
ride on a horse
if you look like you're going like this
a [ __ ] ass I don't even know what else
to talk about man we're 40 minutes in
I'm [ __ ] but this is sometimes when it
gets going the best though what else
happened in Montreal I don't know dude
[ __ ] this you know what I'm I'm gonna go
on a hike tomorrow and here's the thing
till my buddy was like no we can't go my
Irish buddy we can't go when it's hot
out dude that's when you work out we're
not gonna [ __ ] faint my buddy has
stomach problems do it every time it's
too hot he's like almost stomach my
Irish buddy its Dodge he says his Dodge
you know what bothers me about this
[ __ ] I like it and I don't like
it he keeps with his lingo but like when
we meet new people he'll be like yeah
it's Dodge and they'll be like it's what
oh yeah it means it's bad
why explain that every single [ __ ]
time to somebody just lose it but also I
like it I like that he's being true to
him you know that you know that the
[ __ ] you know that your boy likes
that [ __ ] be you man but also [ __ ]
why explain I don't want to have to sit
there so that's the thing be you but
then it affects other people too now I
gotta explain it I gotta sit there all
that means it's bad I gotta [ __ ] be
his translator what did you say about
the [ __ ] political boozing you kinda
you know that means drinking but still
dude don't say booze in my [ __ ]
tweeted about dude I was in I was at Air
Canada I flew to Montreal then I flew
back they didn't have Wi-Fi here's the
thing too I tweeted up let me put the
[ __ ] tweets up got him that thread I
did it was stupid as [ __ ] but I wrote go
- hey Air Canada it's 2018 and then
under it I rode just letting you know
uh just just letting just telling you
because you definitely don't know that
then I wrote actually hold on I'm seeing
what year I'm in because maybe I took a
time machine back to the ages or
something then I wrote I just look at
the newspaper confirm 2018 Air Canada
then I wrote so crazy it's just that the
flight attendant explained to me right
now that there's no internet available
on this flight so I got so confused as
to what year it was I guess you're just
subpar my bad then I wrote tweet me back
and explained the reasoning please I'll
give you six hours to respond and then
in parentheses that's in case you're on
the flight to LA with me because there's
no way you can respond because we were
about to take off and there's no
internet on this flight
people were like okay privileged okay
man stop bitching dude and then they
were referring that louis c.k bit that
he did it if I'm [ __ ] Conan words
like oh yeah you know this is amazing
you're in the sky and Yatta Yatta shut
no dude I don't agree with that bit I
don't agree with that bit man if you
have something in the world that exists
have it have it all these airline people
like will yeah oh this guy's acting like
there aren't [ __ ] airplanes that are
30 years old
ya don't have airplanes that are 30
years old that don't have the Wi-Fi
update don't have that then the Air
Canada wrote hello Chris feel free to DM
us for any assistance Robin I wrote I
can't I'm taking off and you don't
provide Wi-Fi and then president
remember it's 2018 joking and people
were like oh you privileged [ __ ]
this people got so mad I was like and
then I wrote hey Air Canada there's
Wi-Fi at Denny's diner have you been
there besides right now
because that's where I [ __ ] took you
for our Grand Slam for your Bret Grand
Slam breakfast
so dumb and then this guy wrote and it's
2018 you're the less talented version of
Pauly Shore
yet somehow more annoying and he looks
like a [ __ ] penis with a mustache he
looks awful he's got puka shells on I
mean god damn it anyway
but like don't like we get your [ __ ]
up-to-date huge company Oh Canada's
national airline get your [ __ ] up to
date
it was great flight they're great
they're a good airline but like dude
no I don't agree with that [ __ ] like
okay man
what you could firstworldproblems dude
yeah have a [ __ ] internet on your
airplane have internet at your coffee
shop have internet everywhere do you
know why the internet is [ __ ]
enormous and don't have subpar Internet
always have full bars always have full
[ __ ] bars no matter where I go in
your establishment don't have it go one
bar less don't definitely don't have it
go to the last little bitch-ass bar and
that's it because that doesn't work this
is why one fire my studio doesn't have
full bars all the time always have full
bars dude in the airplane - we it exists
dude I know it sounds complaining but I
don't give a [ __ ] man do you have
internet no oh my bad oh my bad it's
just a nineteen people got mad at me
dude [ __ ] you know who gets that mad
at somebody online then I started
slamming people left and right you know
how dad he doesn't he [ __ ] Simon right
and then people were like oh you [ __ ]
somebody this is what they always say -
like oh yeah obviously oh it doesn't
bother you it obviously doesn't get to
you I'm I do it because it's I like
doing it it's funny let's do some
Twitter questions dude come on [ __ ]
let's see what though what do you have a
favorite episode of congratulations pod
Graham Mossad Mossad I don't know man I
always go back to the Michael Caine one
I liked but I like JoJo's Cup because it
got a little personal hey what's with
everybody saying [ __ ] get vulnerable
with your comedy dude then I'll talk
about the last episode that's some [ __ ]
just make it funny all right
uh yeah that might be one of my
favorites but every now and then I get
our new favorite I don't know they're
all my babies right pick another one I
think we already did that one by the way
this what this is a band go up this band
look at this band name my friend she'll
bra found Eric Tyler Mulder depression
Cherry beach house Wow
that's the worst band name ever heard of
my life we've talked about this have
your band name one word and it's [ __ ]
an animal like Beatles or the Lions you
know that's your band name would you
ever do a live this is something hasn't
Sam bridge Sam at Bridge Sam zero zero
would you ever do a live podcast that's
my stand-up bro what does that even mean
they asked me to do it at this festival
they're like would you do
congratulations podcast as a live show
huh
that's my stand-up it would just be
basically a less laughs II version of my
stuff my stand-up what would that I
guess and then I would put it out I
guess I guess I'd put it out I'd have to
have this to [ __ ] it would be like a
good version of my stand-up although
some people like my podcast better than
my stand-up my dad took me sad once and
he was like hey some people were
Sweeting online that they liked your
podcast better than you stand-up how's
that possible like I don't know he's
like you work on your stand-up for
[ __ ] years and podcast sometimes you
say [ __ ] and doesn't even make sense
I was like yeah I know I don't know if
we're gonna like it he goes line when is
that for the beginning of some episode
some guy wrote okay cool this is a good
question Vincent let's lit our dawn a
say Italian what do you do to get
through nights where you feel anxious or
not mentally prepared to perform but
still have to um well you know what I
have a [ __ ] saying well it's not even
a saying but it's something I realized
the first time I did an actual show and
I did stand-up I did had done open mikes
but I hadn't done an actual real show
and I invited some of my friends it was
my first like real actual show and how
many times
I say that but um I didn't understand I
was so nervous and anxious I was like I
got to go onstage but how am I gonna get
offstage I'll get up on stage when they
call my name and I literally thought
okay if I could just move each leg in
front of each other one at a time I'll
eventually I'll be on stage and then
people will be looking at me and I'll be
have to talk I'll have to start talking
so I focused on just moving one of my
legs at a time which is so dumb but it
worked and that brought me around to
thinking about how all you it's all your
body like even if you're anxious
I mean sometimes your anxiety is out of
control I get it mine is too every now
and then but like it is your body and I
think you can control it by trying to
calm yourself down now that doesn't mean
can you control 100% no of course not
but like I used to go to therapy for
years and my therapist would say I used
to get so anxious flying I don't anymore
but she would be like all you have to do
is concentrate on relaxing like you're
not as relaxed as you think you are like
if you think about your body right now
think about where your body is right now
whatever you're doing even if you're
sitting down or whatever
think about the muscle that you're using
right now you're probably you're
probably your abs are probably a little
bit you know tight because you're
sitting up maybe you're you know your
legs across and you're using one leg to
put to use you're you're forcing one leg
to go on top of the other one maybe
you're you know you're [ __ ] holding a
cup of coffee or whatever that whatever
it is you don't realize using those
muscles if you focus I used to focus on
each body part of mine I used to focus
on my calves my feet then I would move
up from there my my [ __ ] my
quadriceps my hamstrings I would I would
sit and I would relax and I would
breathe and I would concentrate on
breathing through it and relaxing each
one of those body parts I get to my
enormous [ __ ] I I try to relax my [ __ ]
you know what I mean not by massaging it
just by breathing to be like relax my
[ __ ] relax my big huge [ __ ] boulder
balls then I get into my my abs and
they're always tight now that's why
like always got the [ __ ] black
diamond course it's like you know
they're always draw a card is very hard
to relax my abs I would do that I
concentrate on my [ __ ] my chest my
[ __ ] crazy crazy [ __ ] rip the
ridiculous chest and you know what
there's a really nice separation between
my chest and my soldiers so I try to
[ __ ] you know relax the striations on
my shoulders and we're gonna do this and
I would do that you know and then I
would get to my [ __ ] tongue which
[ __ ] dances around a woman's mouth
when I kiss her like it's just crazy you
know what I mean and and I'd relax it
and then I would get more relaxed and
the anxiety would go away it would it
would go away sometimes it would go away
completely man but my therapist would
always be like it's your body you can
just do what you have to do by trying to
breathe through it and she was right for
me no granted I'm not the most anxious
person in the world but I think it could
help for you did I used to concentrate
every body part and then I would be not
so anxious being on the airplane and it
worked even relaxing my [ __ ] enormous
[ __ ]
how about well he was a ginormous god
that's so boring okay next you know that
it well you know what guys
a little bit serious on you there who's
gonna join the space force is what I
want to know Trump's a space force Ivan
gets rid of razors head that would be
great if one of you guys would would be
and his space force that's it literally
sounds like a joke movie in the 80s that
[ __ ] Rick Moranis would be in and the
guy from Ernest goes to do the Ernest
movies or whatever space force and Don
John candy would be the lead I'm naming
all the guys in space balls it's not
creative it's like when you [ __ ] what
my buddy KT Tatara has a joke about how
when gross give you the number they're
gonna give you the wrong number they're
not he's like people aren't creative
enough to come up with a whole different
number they always give you the first
eight digits of their number
and then the last digit is the wrong one
she just keep guessing this you know
like nobody's ever like nine four seven
two seven four four seven they're always
do their number whatever it is it's like
3 2 3 4 4 5 4 5 4 4 4 5 5 and then the
last number is different whatever I
thought it was a funny [ __ ] bit I
died maybe you don't like it I I he's
funny alright did pieces of [ __ ] what do
you want from me you got a [ __ ] ya
know [ __ ] yeah dude I we were at that
there was a just for last party or no
party I just for laughs and the [ __ ]
what do you call it and just for laughs
in Montreal and there was a truTV party
and they got and they were like it's the
truTV party and all they had were bagels
and like one piece of meat in it like it
was so sad dude
it was like come on truTV you're really
trying to really trying to get going
with your [ __ ] Network and they give
us [ __ ] sesame bagels with [ __ ]
one slice of Turkey in it and we're like
this is a party
maybe they paid for the bar tab I don't
know but maybe they didn't do it so they
have that Impractical Jokers dude
they're [ __ ] killing it they do they
didn't know apparently they were like
let's try to do a live show they did a
live show and they sold out an arena
that's how big the show wasn't they had
no [ __ ] idea yep they're huge
those guys are [ __ ] rolling in it
those guys are loaded as [ __ ] there's
four rooms so if they have to split it
that's why I do my podcast by myself man
I want that Brinks truck dude I'm not
trying to split it [ __ ] this fighter in
the kid [ __ ] oh they got a split at
dude the [ __ ] out of here
they're always like our podcast is
bigger than yours and I'm like yeah cool
you got to yeah split it [ __ ] I
[ __ ] make more than you because of
that that's what's up dude I don't know
if I do or not but split your [ __ ]
money you [ __ ] fifty two-year-old
Kalen Brendan Schaub you big bully
I love those guys man
I'm gonna [ __ ] take that belt away
from Theo - dude you just watch I'm
gonna melt it down and make him some
[ __ ] nice earrings dude I'm gonna
take that belt that [ __ ] fighter on
the kid belt that Theo von [ __ ] tours
with imagine checking that fam at it
about bringing it on the plane
like you're a lost pro-wrestler and he
brings it around and takes pictures with
fans and that's hilarious by the way
when I get that [ __ ] dude you
babies vote for me TV a que [ __ ]
whatever the acronym is TV a que you get
that [ __ ] Bell for me bro I'm gonna
melt that [ __ ] down mark my words I'm
gonna melt that [ __ ] down and
make some nice dangly earrings for Theo
von - and then [ __ ] gonna wear
them like a housewife you understand
[ __ ] this TV I cash [ __ ] man you big
bully and you fifty two-year-old that's
it I ain't mincing words dude with your
[ __ ] Photoshop promos get out of here
dude Real Deals coming for you man get
out of here with your [ __ ] 4,000
likes on Instagram um anyway I love
doing shows with those guys man comedy
stores the [ __ ] I've been doing the
improv a little bit lately - I'm gonna
be at the Comedy Store all week though
so come see you boy your boy well I
guess that's it man we're 57 minutes in
and you know you're with me through the
end that's the thing we're gonna
announce some elders soon - here we got
to do that we're not gonna do it right
now but thanks for chillin with me you
guys you guys are [ __ ] awesome get
tickets Wichita Kansas Kansas City
Missouri
Lincoln Nevada Reno Nevada Las Vegas I'm
going to London and on to London Ontario
in Ottawa Ontario and Washington DC New
York New York marker
this is the follow-the-leader tour and a
bunch of other dates so go do that
download my app wherever apps wherever
wherever apps are available chris d'elia
just type that into the App Store and
you'll be able to see this podcast
before anyone else Square cash square
cash check out the new boost rewards
program get the cash app and two rewards
code congrats get $5 and give $5 - times
up get it for iOS or Android now
download the app don't forget to
subscribe to the YouTube channel those
will be out usually a day later the
videos and ask us stuff congratulations
pod hashtag and that's it be on the
lookout from a new Netflix thing coming
out you guys are the best
remember [ __ ] Josh
[Music]